Was gibt Schöneres als am Feiertag an seinem Hofdorrum zu bauen?
Oder mal gucken, ob wir das hinkriegen überhaupt?
Ich mein, ich werd euch nicht zeigen wie ich am Hofdorrum baue, aber ich werde jetzt versuchen
die Steuerung hin zu worsten.
Überhaupt noch Platz hier hinten, ja müsste eigentlich passen.
Moin, Tamagulu, war das Tamagulu, oder wie auch immer, es ist schwierig teilweise manche
Twitchnamen auszusprechen, meistens muss man sie auch nicht aussprechen, aber Leute
ich warte, wobei, ich warte noch kurz bis der Stream angelaufen ist.
Moin, Xaito, Serious Max ist am Start, Leon, Angel, Kick, nein, Klick, klickt und auch,
Moment, Moment, weder Angel noch Kick, es ist Leon angeklickt, Leon, Angel, Kick, Alter,
das war ein bisschen, ah ja, danke schön für den Prime Sub, Twitch, Mason, Calimero,
MgPux, SilverCross hat auch ein Glückesub, danke schön, Leute, Gampel0, Vivian, MyAlly
ist auch wieder am Start.
Hattest du mir nicht, nicht dass ich dir das jetzt durchreinabringen, hattest du mir
nicht eine Mail wegen irgendeinem Job geschrieben vor einem halben Jahr oder so, ich hab mich
da glaub ich nie gemeldet mehr zu, ich hab's irgendwie schon komplett verdrängt, jetzt
wo ich den Namen grad seh, fällt es mir gerade ein, ah, null, ich bin echt planlos, wenn
so was angeht.
Tja, ich weiß nicht, wie weit das noch aktuell ist, ich bin da eigentlich immer noch am gucken.
So, Stream ist an, also Leute, ich zeige euch mal kurz, was wir heute machen, mal gespannt
ob das funktioniert, weil ich hab ewig kein Shelly mehr benutzt, ewig nicht, also, seit,
das war noch vor Corona, wo ich mal ein Shelly eingerichtet habe, Arbeit wird überbewertet,
einfach Geld verdienen, ja gut, einfach Geld, das stimmt wohl, einfach Geld verdienen mach
ich ja mit YouTube nebenbei, das heißt, wenn es danach geht, ähm, eigentlich, warum geh
ich überhaupt noch arbeiten, ich mach jetzt noch ein paar Genshin Impact Sponsorings weiter.
Der Boost Train, ja, das ist was Neues, ich hab's auch noch nicht so genau gecheckt, also
ich glaube, ich glaube, der Boost Train ist quasi ein einmaliger Hype Train, es kann sein,
dass es kompletter Mist ist, was ich erzähle, ein einmaliger Hype Train, der dazu führt,
dass der Stream auf mehreren Stellen von Twitch empfohlen wird und so quasi mehr Viewer dazu,
fragt mich nicht, keine Ahnung, ist mir auch, ist mir auch vollkommen egal, na aktuell sind
meine Stunks nicht so geil, also mein ETF, wie heißt das, Depot, ne wie nennt man das,
Plan, ach was auch immer, ist um über 2500 Euro runtergegangen jetzt, Portfolio, ja gut,
wenn du es so willst, ja ETF sind ja mehrere, sind ja ganz viele Aktien zusammen, nur dass
ich mich nicht drum kümmere, jaja, also ich zeige euch mal, ich will nämlich meinen Hoftor,
also ich muss euch erst mal erzählen warum, also ich habe mir ja ein neues Auto gekauft,
das wisst ihr ja, ich mache mal die ganzen Kram vom letzten Mal zu, hier, blublublublublublublublublublu,
oh nein, oh jetzt hab ich den Chat zugemacht, na ganz schlau, Massify IQ, wilder Igel, Dankeschön
für den, für den Zapp, der Name kommt mir bekannt vor, spielst du Zelda, spielst du
link to the past randomizer den namen habe ich schon mal irgendwo gehört
dann ist schon für die 1111 milliarden bit also jetzt kann ich euch jetzt kann
ich euch mal was erzählen also ich habe mir ein neues auto gekauft das wisst ihr
ich habe mir einen 4500 e gekauft das habe ich euch ja schon erzählt das
müssen wir nicht weiter weiter breit treten so und eine sache die mir
persönlich extremst auf den kicks geht ist wenn ich in den hof fahren möchte
dass ich dann das hof von hand aufmachen muss also ich muss dann quasi
irgendwo hin an die seite zum toftor aufmachen reinfahren zumachen sagt ich
bin früher nie reingefahren in den hof mit dem alten auto aber bei dem alten
auto habe ich mir auch keine keine sorgen gemacht dass es jemand beschädigt
oder klaut bei dem neuen wäre ich mir da nicht so sicher
mein alten agila wollte niemand klauen aber mein neuen fiat war auch kaputt
machen ich meine der agila hätte den kaputt gemacht wäre wahrscheinlich
noch im wert gestiegen also insofern die einzelnteile wenn wahrscheinlich mehr
wert gewesen als das auto zusammen insofern ist es kein ding aber bei dem
neuen auto sieht es natürlich anders aus und deswegen möchte ich mein hof
automatisch auf und zu machen deswegen habe ich mir diesen krempel da gekauft
der wink der winkel von dieser kamera sagt halt echt so ein bisschen aber ich
zeige euch ich zeige euch das mal kurz ich mache das mal kurz groß also was
haben wir denn hier also was ich habe ich habe so nicht ausprobiert leute legit
also die kombination ich habe so nicht ausprobiert keine ahnung also das
einzige was schon gemacht ich habe ich habe unten eine wie heißt das ein
beschlag nennt sich das glaube ich das hat ja alles immer so tolle fachbegriffe
für alles an die wand gemacht und geguckt ob das überhaupt funktionieren
würde also was haben wir hier wir haben ein jelly 3 warum habe ich den jelly 3
genommen näher weil er drei relays hat zum schalten und ich glaube das brauche
ich dafür und ich hatte noch ein deswegen hat sich das angeboten
man könnte es auch mit dem x beliebigen sp 32 machen und ein paar relays ich glaube
auf die mit den gpa aus sollte ich hier allerdings eher nicht dran weil das in
24 volt und wahrscheinlich grills mit an mann sp
gehe ich jetzt einfach mal von aus ja
so und dann haben wir hier also das hier ist die das ist die steuerung und das
was ihr hier neben seht was leider nicht so ganz in die kamera passt ich versuche
es jetzt aber das sind das sind das ist zwei sind zwei motoren mit so einem
antrieb für den mal gucken ob ich das wenn ich so rum gehe irgendwie halbwegs
reinhalten kann
guck mal so sieht das aus ja das macht man dann vorne also die sind auch
relativ schwer ja also das macht man hier vorne ans hoftor dran und dann
fährt diese dieses ding fährt halt raus und rein vielleicht vielleicht kann ich
so hinlegen dass man es gleich sieht keine ahnung spätestens wenn sich
bewegt muss ich es eh festhalten sonst sonst wird das nix
also ich glaube tricks läuft gerade einmal im haus vorbei hier läuft
jemand vorbei das sieht original aus ich weiß zwar nicht was der in hanau macht
aber wer weiß ne das ist ja nicht aber das sehr dem schon verdammt ähnlich
gerade ja also das ist ein motor bei links und
2 2 2 mal 2 mal motor und intern funktioniert das ganze also hier ist
halt anschluss an die steckdose und die motoren schließt man hiermit an das ist
24 volt so also das erste was wir jetzt mal probieren ist ich schließe die
motoren hier an und guck mal ob die überhaupt rein und raus fahren so und
wenn die dann rein und raus fahren was ist hier für ein gelege
naja geht so so wenn die motoren an rein und raus fahren dann schließen wir den
jelly an so und soweit ich das soweit ich das
gecheckt habe ist das folgendermaßen
man kann an der stelle hier zeigt euch mal kurz auf dem bild
guck mal da sind doch hier so alter was für gelege kamera keg weight alter
warum ich so ein teures handy wenn es rum leckt so ihr seht hier du kannst
button 1 und button 2 dran machen so und da unten steht auch weiß ich auch mal
das erkennt da steht g tür und das steht im puls und wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe hier das quasi über brücken schaltet das komplette tor und
das hier nur die g tür das ist je nachdem die frage wie es hier dran
anschließt das probieren wir aber gleich aus ungefähr 200 euro das set ja das
kommt nee das set ist ein bisschen teurer gewesen also ich habe ich zeige
euch mal was das für ein antrieb ist das ist ein sommer 200 eh nein ja alter ich
hatte wieder mega glück keg weight ich habe 500 540 oder irgendwie so was
dafür bezahlt aber so ein set ist das zweimal motor das ist das was sie hier
oben liegen sie da dann einmal die steuerungs box und so verankerungs
dinger für die wand und das ist eine fernbedienung die habe ich auch
irgendwo aber die brauche ich nicht man kann auch hier drücken dann zum
testen das habe ich schon schon nachgeguckt so als heißt als erste
schließen wir das mal an ich das dumme ist ich habe halt hier nicht nicht mehr
platz also ich krieg die dinger sind halt relativ groß ja ich meine die teile
sind bis zu einem guck mal zweifel 2,5 meter breiter oder 300 kilo also das ist
schon relativ stabil und groß das passt ja halt nicht passt hier nicht
gescheit in die kamera und hier dahinter ist halt direkt direkt die wand auf der
seite ist direkt die wand dahinter dass das da ihr seht ihr ein bisschen die
heizung unten noch das da geht es halt auch nicht weiter und seit ich die so
hingelegt dass es irgendwie dass ihr gescheit was sieht aber ich wenn wir
das drücken ich halte es dann so irgendwie mal die kamera dass man es
halbwegs sieht müssen wir mal gucken
vielleicht vielleicht kann ich es auch festhalten ist dann so rum so rum
hinlegen oder so übrigens das handbuch ist richtig kacke das kann man komplett
vergessen da blickt keiner durch die beschreibung die beschreibung hier
drin ist aber ganz ok ja so sieht es aus chat öffnet das tor nach innen oder
außen das öffnet nach innen
das weiß ich nicht du kannst auf jeden fall von hand stoppen mit einem
knopfdruck oder einem esp also die knöpfe also die bedienung muss von
folgendermaßen sein du drückst drauf dann sagen wir fährt auf und wenn noch
mal drauf drückst bleibt stehen und wenn du noch mal drauf drückst fährt es in die
andere richtung ich glaube dass das die fall verhalten wenn ich das richtig
gesehen habe ja und du kannst auch den stopp moment doch dass das geht du
kannst den stopp einstellen du kannst den stopp hier vorne irgendwo einstellen
das kann ich euch gar nicht zeigen da muss ich den mal rein fahren du hast
dann du hast hier vorne was du hast irgendwo hier vorne was da kannst du
dran drehen wo das stoppt also standardmäßig fährt es halt 90 90 grad
auf also was das 90 grad standardmäßig fährt es voll das kann man aber
irgendwie einstellen an diesem stopper ja das geht das geht auch
moin sarex dass das funktioniert also ich würde sagen ich schließe es jetzt
erstmal an und wir gucken ob es dann überhaupt auf und zu fährt und zum
einfachheit halber des testens würde ich dann einer dieser dinger dahinten
einer dieser motoren die mache ich wieder ab und legt die da unten
ach so achtung leute fai fett fai fett alarm ich hatte ich hatte eine idee die
beste anordnung bei meinem hof da ist nämlich folgendermaßen
warte mal wir machen mal wir machen mal drohr punkt i o
die seitlater hat haben die hier irgendwie ein dohr ja exzellent guck
mal sich sein also wenn das hier jetzt mein hof toll ist
das hier wenn das hier mein hof toll ist dann
man hat ja auch so dinger immer noch stellvertretend so ein teil hier
das exquisite zeug immer noch stellvertretend dieses dieses ding hier
soll das eigentlich alles sein ja nehmen wir mal das hier stellvertretend für so
einen motor ja so und also die die beste die beste variante ist das ist ja
beschissen das ist die kiste hier so kiste kiste kiste ist so ein motor so die
beste variante ist bei mir folgendermaßen kommt man bei trauer auch nicht so
irgendwie die fein nicht rechts normalerweise menü für die farbe oder
bin ich jetzt bin ich jetzt irgendwie verwirrt und wenn man nicht die farbe
normalerweise rechts einstellen oder war das hier viel color ja wunderbar
so also die beste anordnung von den motoren bei meinem tor ist folgendes
einmal hier weil das ist auch nicht ganz symmetrisch also ist nicht so wie
nicht nicht so wie hier einmal hier und einmal so wäre die beste anordnung für
das ding weil hier ist noch ein bisschen platz dahinter dass man das gut gut an
die wand machen kann in plus ist hier ist direkt das haus vom nachbar auf der
seite das heißt das ding muss sich außen muss
ich außen platzieren also sprich der da muss das tor aufdrücken
und der muss das aufziehen was bedeutet ich muss die zwei motoren
unterschiedlich anschließen also ich muss einmal hier den den für den großen
flügel den muss ich als rum anschließen dass er quasi rausgeht beim öffnen und
den hier muss ich richtig rum anschließen dass er rein fährt beim
öffnen also ist ja logisch das ding hängt an das ding hängt so da das ding
hängt standardmäßig ist standardmäßig das so und dann macht das tor auf und
fährt halt auf fährt halt auf und in der zeit drückt sein halt so dass das
bleibt der das ist jetzt beschissen zu malen aber ihr versteht wahrscheinlich so
so ungefähr wird dann wird dann die anordnung von dem ding sein das heißt
ich muss auch mal gucken ob das funktioniert den ein so rum anschließen
den anderen so rum anschließen aber das müsste funktionieren weil man kann den
einfach so rum dran richtig rum dran klemmen und den anderen umgedreht ran
klemmen und dann ja dann sollte das funktionieren so weit von der idee
bei kriege da bin ich beruhigt wenn der chat agreed dann kann eigentlich nix
mehr schiefgehen
moin wo macht man hier noch mal
und macht mir noch mal timestamps an achter
dass ich ordentlich was sehen wobei ich sehe es eigentlich auch so ganz gut ja
leute so sieht es aus das probieren wir jetzt gibt es auch irgendwelche
neugierigkeiten chat ist heute so ruhig chat lauscht mir wahrscheinlich einfach
nur gebannt oder
alle bettke ja sieht echt so aus
mannerweise wird hier rumgespammt wie sonst was chat zockt so was was spielt
was spielt in der chat sag jetzt nicht bettel viel 2042 wirklich ernsthaft ja
ernsthaft ja gentschen impact ja dann wart ihr vielleicht auch jetzt in der
wüste du machst daily scrum
chat müde chat schlafen ja freust du dich auf call of duty 2022 naja meine
freude hältst den grenzen ich habe die beta gespielt und ich finde die
neuauflage generell so komplett bankrotterklärung kreative bankrotterklärung
dass das ist überhaupt existiert dass es überhaupt gibt ich fand den reboot
schon fragwürdig weil ich mein wollen die 2029 dann wenn wieder alles durch
ist und noch mal rebooten oder was oder als nächstes wird black ops rebooted ich
sage es euch leute wollen wir wetten das nächste was kommt ist black ops 1 rebooted
das wird wahrscheinlich dann auch gut laufen
aber halt in schlecht weil original modern war für eins war um längeren
besser als mw 2019 und black ops 1 kriegen die wahrscheinlich auch nicht
mehr remake ordentlich da gucken wir doch mal also ich schließe das jetzt mal an
und dann gucken wir ob das mit dem rein und raus fahren wie gesagt ich habe
nicht so viel platz hier hinten ist die steckdosen leiste was macht denn diese
maus maus gehen wir fort hier hinten steht die steckdosen leiste hier steht
ein switch sieht man nicht da steht ein switch hier ist der tisch schon zu ende
also viel passt da nicht drauf
cold war naja cold war war ja kein kein reboot von black ops so also wir machen
jetzt erstmal hier kurz die schrauben raus
es ist schon schon mitgedacht so und dann stecken wir das mal dran also was
haben wir denn hier ich hoffe das reicht jetzt auch von
der fernung so welchen seht ihr besser den dag ja dann machen wir mal nur den
da dran und gucken ob das funktioniert einfach mal anschließen gucken ob es
funktioniert sollte sollte eigentlich relativ easy sein man muss normalerweise
ist es so gedacht dass man das hier durch diese durch diese wasserdichten
stöpsel macht aber das machen wir jetzt nicht weil wozu hier das liegt da
eh noch rum und ich krieg es nicht richtig raus wenn ich das richtig gesehen
habe hier in der anleitung dann muss das folgendermaßen angeschlossen werden
guckt mal ich weiß nicht warum es immer leckt wenn ich was einblende motor 1
braunes kabel zuerst dann blaues kabel das ist wenn man will dass aufmachen
reingehen ist und das zumachen raus raus raus also dass tor auf hier das
einfahren und tor rein dass das rausfahren so das ist glaube ich die fall
das heißt wir machen das jetzt auch mal sofern man da überhaupt gescheit
hinkommt aber haben sogar schon ordentliche
ade enthülsen drüber gemacht dass das auch ordentlich hält schon mal nicht
schlecht das rein und das rein dann schrauben wir das mal fest dann mache
ich an und wir drücken den knopf und gucken ob es rein und raus fährt wenn es
nicht rein und raus fährt dann muss ich noch irgendwie an diesem komischen dip
schalter da oben was machen
was hier gebastelt wird also das da sind zwei motoren mit solchen dingern dran
die man ans hoftor machen kann und das ist die steuerung dafür und dann geht
das hof vor auf und zu wenn man das wenn man das also wenn man das muss man die
wandschrauben und diese das macht man ans hoftor das da das also dieser beschlag
kommt ans hofte dann fährt das rein und raus und wird hinten an der wand fest
kann man auch ein bisschen platz links und rechts und ich habe nur auf einer
seite platz das heißt das eine muss ich draußen dran machen das andere drin
ja und das ist die steuerung
genau jetzt testen wir noch mal ob das funktioniert wo ist denn der stecker da
also die stecker ist natürlich wieder ganz ganz besonders toll hier platziert
so ich mache jetzt mal den stecker rein und dann gucken wir mal was passiert
ich meine rauchen kann nix es ist alles angeschlossen es ist alles in
auslieferungszustand großartig kaputt gehen kann da nix aber mal an
so da unten sollte ich jetzt besser nicht mein finger rein stecken also es
blinkt ist es blinken gut oder schlecht
hieß du nicht damals informat ja mein ingame name mein ingame name machen wir
mal so dass ihr auch was gescheit erkennen könnt so es blinkt wenn ich das
jetzt richtig verstanden habe und ich jetzt diesen knopf da drücke dann
sollte der hier gleich ausfahren das problem ist nur da muss ich hier hinten
festhalten weil ansonsten fällt er runter testen wir mal
nee
gatschi gasm leute er wird länger
guck mal er moved stop
und wieder rein
ok dass das funktioniert schon mal gatschi roll
das schon mal gut dass es dass es einfach so geht das das das ist schon mal von
vorteil so und woher weiß ich jetzt ob er auf oder zu fährt sie können muss
jetzt noch mal ich muss jetzt noch mal drücken und halt gucken dass es hier
nicht runterfällt weil ich habe hier relativ wenig platz so noch mal drücken
ah guck dir mal da steht jetzt zu das erkennt ihr nicht richtig da die led hier
die da leucht die ist für zu und die da neben der grün ist für auf das heißt
wenn ich jetzt hier stopp drücke
und jetzt geht es auf also das heißt auf bedeutet in dem fall so rum
angeschlossen aber ich habe es falsch rum angeschlossen oder ich habe es
falsch ich habe ich habe es glaube ich falsch rum angeschlossen kommt mal jetzt
geht er jetzt geht er jetzt geht er zu zu doch ist auch richtig das tor wird
geschlossen indem er rausfährt er drückt ja dann quasi das tor zu und auf ist
wenn er das rein zieht dann zieht er das tor quasi auf ja doch das ergibt sinn
ja doch doch das ergibt sinn in dem fall das ist richtig richtig so was ich
gelesen wisst ihr was wir testen das nur mit einem das reicht den anderen mache
ich den anderen mache ich dann dann wieder weg
so ich habe gelesen wenn ich das hier jetzt umdrehe also quasi braun da in 2
und und blau in 1 dann geht das ganze umgedreht was im endeffekt bedeuten
würde ich kann eins rausfahren lassen zum schließen und eins reinfahren lassen
zum schließen was ich muss wenn ich das eine aus und das andere hin montieren
will ob immer das auch noch mal kurz aus also hier drinnen muss man sich auch
nicht viele gedanken machen die das ganze ding läuft mit 24 volt außer hier
unten da muss man natürlich gucken da geht da geht die steckdose dran also da
unten sollte man nicht unbedingt rumfingern der rest wird ein wahrscheinlich
auch nicht umbringen man sollte natürlich immer den stecker
rausziehen bevor man was da drin macht ist klar ich habe auch den stecker
rausgezogen gerade ich sehe nichts weil die kamera im weg ist bin ich bin ich
richtig muss man kurz rumdrehen
so jetzt ist das blau zuerst drin
ich mache ich erst den stecker wieder rein also ich sunset leute nicht da drin
rum
sich da zu wenig gedanken machen und am endeffekt gehts dann nach hinten los also das ist auch
ne sache da hab ich wirklich bisschen immer so meine bedenken so jetzt haben wir es andersrum
angeschlossen das heißt jetzt ist gar nix aha guck mal jetzt ist auf jetzt ist auf
rausfahren und zu es rein fahren das ist genau umgedreht wie das letzte mal
genau funktioniert also die eigentliche steuerung ist easy die eigentliche steuerung
ist tatsächlich relativ einfach die dieser dieser dip switch da kannst du das habe ich
im handbuch von geguckt als leute das handbuch ist wirklich größte größte pepega werk was
sie was sie mal was sie je gesehen habt aber stecker wieder raus größte pepega werk was
sie je gesehen habt leute also wer das wer das geschrieben hat wirklich wirklich kein plan also
dabei ist es dabei ist es eigentlich relativ einfach bloß also die beschreibung ist wirklich
ganz ganz wir ja und auf diesen auf diesem switch hier kann man umstellen ob man beispielsweise
einen ein tor mit geht für ein zweiflügeliges tor ein einflügeliges tor was auch immer ich
lasse aber standardmäßig erstmal alles so du hast das geschrieben glaube ich dir sofort
wer noch chat das ist der punkt wo dann der halbe chat normalerweise schreibt nein nein ich
wobei das im deutschsprachigen raum auf twitch nicht so soll ich sagen nicht so angesagt ist
aber im englischsprachigen bereich ist es jeder jeder wenn irgendwie einer sagt ich habe das
gemacht kommt der nächste no i made this no me das stimmt stimmt das stimmt das frech
ein vorteil ist es handbuch in papierform richtig also ich muss echt sagen dass diese
kamera dass die iphone kamera hier so laggy ist teilweise ist wirklich nicht so nicht so
dolle überlegt was was ein ding kostet ja und es sein euch die kamera auch nicht irgendwie
die übertragung weil das wird das wird ja an sich anderweitig äußern ok also die steuerung
an sich funktioniert jetzt ist natürlich nur die große preisfrage wenn ich hier unten
die kontakte schalte also die da die zwei also 13 und 14 da ihr guckt da das ist das
sind quasi dann auch die dinger die ich mit dem jelly schalten muss funktioniert das also
wenn ich die hier schalte impuls also wenn ich die quasi überbrücke dann ist das quasi
das gleiche wie wenn ich den knopf drücke das probieren wir probieren wir doch mal aus
machen wir noch mal strom dran haben wir noch mal strom dran und ich hole jetzt mal ein
drück draht was heißt draht den kabel so kommen wir mal also impuls 13 und 14 so von
der idee her macht er jetzt was excellent michael 50 billionen moin danke schön für
den sub so das heißt wenn ich das jetzt überbrücke 13 und 14 dann sollte der von der idee
her aufgehen es hat geklickt er machte easy guck funktioniert jetzt geht er wieder zu
wunderbar wunderbar kann ich viel drehen die kamera ist da oben fest und hier hier geht
es auch nicht weiter ist halt nicht so viel es ist normalerweise auch nicht brauche ich
das auch nicht um hier irgendwie großartige dinger drauf drauf zu legen aus leckt das
stream hat gut geleckt habe ich genau gesehen gut das funst ja geht trotz spukig musik
excellent gut also das funst und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie den jelly anschließen und gucken
wie das wie das geht leute ich habe wie gesagt das ist ein jahr her oder so wo ich ein jahr
sind drei jahre her oder so wo ich letztes mal jelly benutzt habe was kann man das genau
macht hab schon mal ein ipad für oder wie weiß der jelly dann was als nächstes kommt
der jelly weiß das gar nicht der jelly weiß das gar nicht der jelly kann nur seine relays
an und ausschalten das muss die das muss deine steuerung muss das wissen also du musst
dir dann also dort wo du den jelly einbindest wirst du dir dann halt einen button machen
für tor auf oder tötet tor zu und was dann das jeweilige relay schaltet man kann sich
den status glaube ich auch irgendwo hier auslesen glaubt man kann den status irgendwie auch
an den das hat hier irgendwie auch zwei relays und kann den status glaube ich auch hier irgendwie
abgreifen was passiert wenn du ein signal gibst obwohl sich der motor noch bewegt dann
stoppt er was ist ein jelly noch gleich das ding im endeffekt ist das ist das hier quasi
dann ein esp 32 könnte das schon sein esp 32 mit eingebauten relays zum schalten der
24 volt 24 volt tauglich ist weil die normalen esp 32 halt also generell ein esp 32 hält
bloß 3,3 volt aus beziehungsweise 5 aber intern ist 3,3 und die haben es halt so gemacht dass
du es mit 24 betreiben kannst aber da ist natürlich ein spannungswandel drin dass
der esp im endeffekt auch nur mit 3,3 volt betrieben wird aber das wichtige ist ja dass
die sachen selbst 24 volt aushalten und wenn das ding dann eben auch mit 24 volt betreiben
kann weil hier drinnen habe ich nur einen anschluss wir müssen mal gucken wie man den
jelly dann da rankriegen ich kann es nur hier dran machen so wie es aussieht guck mal warnlicht
ich kann es ans warnlicht machen nee ans warnlicht hier dc 24 volt oder was was was bedeutet
was steht da ov ach nee das ist ground das ist also das ist das ist das ist ground und
das hier ist plus 24 volt also im endeffekt ich muss das wahrscheinlich dann so rum anschließen
den jelly so rum da dran das müssen wir jetzt ausprobieren ich wie gesagt keine ahnung hat
der jelly in irgendeiner art und weiß hat der jelly vielleicht in der led dass ich sehe ob er
an ist oder nicht ich habe wirklich ewig kein jelly mehr benutzt also das letzte mal hat
jemand von euch in letzter zeit mal jelly eingerichtet also das letzte mal ist die
jelly eingerichtet habe ging es auf zwei arten erstens über die app zweitens über
irgendeinen hotspot von denen die es das ding aufmacht hat er nicht in sommer der jelly
wir gucken noch mal kurz wir gucken noch mal kurz weil es kann durchaus sein dass man den um
was jetzt picture in picture alter was ich was das wieder hat genau so und jetzt müssen wir
erst mal das handbuch vom jelly gucken ob man den irgendwie umschalten muss auf 24 volt guck
den also den kannst du betreiben mit 24 bis 60 volt dc oder 230 volt ac allerdings soweit
ich mich erinnern kann wenn du die gpa aus ver wobei ich will ja die gpa aus gar nicht
benutzen ich will eigentlich nur die relays verwenden müssen wir mal schauen was der was
der was der kann ich bin da gerade bisschen planlos app guide user safety guide gibt es
irgendwie wir wir in die diagramm oder sowas hier guck mal genau power supply 24 volt dc hier da ja
gut das dachte ich mir an ist auch im moment falsch rum ich hätte es halt ist es leute ich
hätte es jetzt ich hätte es klart klart falsch rum angeschlossen rot ist minus da das ist das
das noch mal erleben das ist normalerweise immer egal normalerweise normalerweise ist rot eigentlich
immer plus aber gut wenn sie meinen genau rot ist minus und blau ist plus k und das hier sind dann
die relays im endeffekt so das sind die gpi aus von dem von dem chip was ich nicht brauche
weil ich will ihn ja gar nicht flaschen will er die stock firmware verwenden da hat es
ein reset button also anscheinend muss ich nichts umstellen alter monka es ok das einzige was uns
interessiert ist way to dank hat er wählen ja
ja tiger flashbang ich verstehe es auch nicht so ganz normalerweise hast du jetzt
rote kabel eigentlich immer plus aber ok man wenigstens steht da sich auch so ein beipackzettel ok
wisst ihr was wir schließen es jetzt einfach mal an und gucken ob es abbraucht oder nicht kacke
ich muss mal kurz mein tablet holen weil ich was brauche um in den exes den exes point vom
jelly zu gehen wie viele 3 hast du in reserve gar kein mir fällt aber auch grad was auf ich
glaube das funktioniert überhaupt nicht was ich was ich vorhabe schaut mal das ist nichts was
ich schalten kann oder der kann nur moment moment das sind nur inputs oder hier das ist ja kacke
da kann ich das ding überhaupt nicht verwenden ja das ist ja kacke das bringt mir ja gar nichts
der kann quasi an drei inputs feststellen ob da spannung jetzt will ich ja gar nicht ich will
ja ich ich will ja quasi das was ist das für einen kacke ich meine ich habe irgendwie auch
noch ein was ich habe doch noch ich habe doch ein jelly eins habe ich auch noch irgendwo
was haben die ich habe ich habe ein paar sachen von denen noch rumliegen jelly plus zwei ist das
mit zwei relays okay das mit zwei aber ich glaube ich glaube den jelly zwei habe ich nicht hier
ja dreimal input ja das ist ja reudig das bringt mir doch gar nichts ok so was so was bräuchte ich
dann oder oder sekunde oder wir machen den esp 32 dran im spannungswandler davor man das
ihr müsst in den chat wer ist auf zack was ist denn das das müsste glaube ich hier da steht
es doch was es ist ein lm 2596 schauen wir mal machen wir halt machen ich halt dann esp 32 mit
mit relays rein so lm jetzt habe ich nicht aufgepasst was 2 596 dc dc wandler step down modul
genau das was haben wir zu bieten 30 bis 40 auf 1,5 bis 3,5 voll ja das ist gut so was brauche
man kann ich in esp 32 da muss ich jetzt mal in meiner kiste kramen was brauche ich denn
dafür also ich brauche in spannungs nicht das bringt mir gar nichts scheiße das bringt mir
moment moment ok mal kurz jetzt bin ich verwirrt doch das geht mein esp sieht ja sie sind ja keine
24 volt am input am input für die gpi aus ne ne das passt das das geht das geht
was machen die relays dahinten
brauchst du nicht zwei wandler ne warum
but why
ich muss nicht schreiben ne ne ich brauche also von der idee her ich bin mir da nicht ganz sicher ob
das jetzt funktioniert also ich brauche entspannungs wandler für den esp 32 der kommt da dran
so also das ding das ding plus in esp 32 brauche ich
ich habe doch irgendwo hier noch welche ja und esp 32 also so spannungs wandler
sp 32 und ich brauche zwei relays ich habe mir mal so einen so einen china chinesen 20er pack
gekauft aber ich weiß gerade nicht wo ich die habe wenn ich ehrlich bin schau mal mal ich
mache mal meine magische magic controller box auf und schau mal ob dort nicht dass da meine
adresse irgendwo drauf steht check wait schau mal ob da irgendwelche relays drin sind jetzt haben
ein hier ach guck mal ich habe auch noch ich habe auch noch esp 866 demo und minis die sind
vielleicht sogar besser weil warum soll ich in esp 32 für so was so was einfaches verschwenden
so haben wir irgendwelche relays da da sind noch welche aber das sind die das sind die fetten die
braucht man in dem fall gar nicht ich habe ich habe irgendwo so ein kleines so ein zweier pack
relays irgendwo meine güte alter was weiß ich denn wo ich den kram habe jetzt
das nix noch mehr spannungs wandler upps
na gut ich lasse das mal draußen weil vielleicht machen wir es damit so haben wir ganz viel
habe ich sonst keine da hier hier habe ich noch eins aber ich habe mir mal irgendwo so
ein sonst ok das ist chat da sind vielleicht ein bisschen viel dafür oder oder kann man
die auseinander brechen ne kann man nicht oder ich hatte mal so ganz kleine was dafür echt gut
gut wäre aber weiß jetzt nicht wo die kleinung hat zwischendurch genau muss ich muss ich mal
schauen wo ich die habe also das mal kurz aufmachen und reingucken ob man die irgendwie
auseinander machen kann na geil vielleicht bisschen viele des guten die kann man auch
nicht auseinander machen die sind hier unten china chinesen action kann man auch nicht auseinander
ne das bringt mir gar nix dann müssen wir müssen was damit dann müssen was damit machen guck mal
ich habe sogar ist das ein relay mit mit leds ob es an oder aus ist das wäre natürlich auch
nicht verkehrt oder ist natürlich gleich vertrauens erwecken guck mal eine sekunde
seht ihr china china china chinesen beschriftung da weißt du bescheid zwei transistoren sollen
warte mal du hast recht du hast recht und ich habe auch welche aber ich weiß nicht wo die waren
aber das ist so ein bastel set wann waren die dabei genau ihr habt recht ich habe auch welche ich
habe aber am besten willen gerade keine ahnung wo ich das habe ich packe erst mal kurz dieses
riesen relating wieder weg ach du wo habe ich das denn das werde ich jetzt nicht finden was
ist das hier sekunde leute was ist das ich habe noch so ein bastel so ein bastel dir ein
touch bastel dir ein touch display set gefunden vielleicht ist da ja was drin easy die haben es
richtig verkackt oder warum heißt das nicht warum heißt das nicht die delivery warum heißt das
delivery guck mal ob da so was drin ist muss so gucken ob dann irgendwo die adresse drauf
sind was haben wir denn hier guck mal ein display was ich alles für den kram da hab guck mal ein
2,8 zoll tft display easy jumper gedöns und ein display ach du kacke was ist das das ist
einfach nur die platine da ist nichts da mache ich auch da mache ich auch nichts dran mache ich
wieder zu und lass es mein original im original wo habe ich denn dieses kit ich habe mir nämlich
welche gekauft das weiß ich genau dass ich mir welche gekauft habe das waren so kleine
tütchen die habe ich glaube ich bei konrad online bestellt sogar noch oder bei nie reichelt oder
konrad irgendwo online shit wo könnte ich das hin haben vielleicht liegt hier noch auf dem
schreibtisch irgendwo wartet mal mal gucken ich glaube zwar nicht ich habe schon lange nichts
mehr davon gesehen aber ok ich liegt seit einfach seit irgendwie drei jahren oder so auf dem
schreibtisch aber sieht nicht so aus ne ne ne nope nope das ist so kleinkram immer ab und zu mal
braucht irgendwie alle lichtjahre was weiß ich wo ich das hin hab meine güte monka schreibtisch
das waren so kleine tütchen ich erinnere mich noch dunkel aber ich habe meine kreditkarte
wieder gefunden pock weiß schon gefragt wo die ist er und blond esp gefunden wo habe ich
denn diese kleinen tütchen hin mensch ok leute war ich muss ich muss ja um mich gucken warte mal
ich habe noch irgendwo so eine bastel box
ok ich habe einen teil gefunden der bestellung bei konrad sind leider nur widerstehende
brauchen wir vielleicht auch noch wirklich ganz sicher meine meine güte wo könnte ich das denn
haben ich bin verwirrt wo könnte ich das haben wir können auch einfach mal mit dem relay weitermachen
ist doch ist doch im prinzip egal wir machen wir machen einfach mal mit dem mit dem normalen relay
weiter ich meine warum sollte ich ist jetzt erstmal wurscht das ist natürlich geil also leute wenn
ihr wissen wollt welche inputs was sind hier easy sagt mir mal was ist welche input obvius
oder sagt mal was ist was gecommeriz am start ja die wissen das hier hier ok bei dem erkennt
man guckt mal normally open normally closed und hier hinten hast du dann hier hinten hast
du den den den ok den input trotzdem ich weiß genau ich habe welche ich habe mir nämlich damals
ein packen bestellt das waren das waren einmal die widerstände dann war das das habe ich nämlich
gebraucht für meine tür gegen sprechanlage damals dann waren irgendwelche zehner pack
transistor dinger wo habe ich denn das war ich gehe noch mal kurz in die kiste kurz wühlen
ich habe da was ich habe da was vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht ist da was drin guck
mal ich habe noch ein upgraded electronics funkit vielleicht vielleicht haben wir da welche
drinne chat was meint ihr haben wir da ein paar transistoren drinne ja oder also ich brauche kein
es gibt doch da auch irgendwie vier verschiedene sorten meint meint ihr das was drin mein
electronics fun muss so was drinne sein elektronik fun übrigens immer dran denken stecke raus
electronics fun happy customer so widerstände happy customer irgendwelche breadboards die ich
nicht brauche happy fun mehr wiederstellt alter was ist das für ein china chinesen crap alle
das liegt ja einfach so drinne aha aha nee buttons ich dachte schon hier guck mal da das
sieht das sieht gut aus leute das sieht gut aus jetzt ist nur die frage was ist das welche sind
das das sieht gut aus achtung schau mal mal was ist das was sind das für welche ja also
der optik nach würde ich sagen ist das schon so was was wir suchen der pn 222 801 ok easy
pn pn 222 801 general purpose transistors exzellent exzellent guck mal da steht sogar pin out und in
und so ja sehr schön so was brauchen wir oder chat ich bin da nicht ich bin da nicht so super
ich bin also nicht der krasseste ich weiß ungefähr was ich mache ich bin nicht der
krasseste checker was elektronik zeug angeht aber ich meine ich habe zumindest schon mal durchgucken
erkannt dass es wahrscheinlich ist also bisschen bisschen was habe ich mittlerweile auch gelernt
so also gut oder müsste mir helfen bei jetzt das wird das wird was
dass das wird was ok also die widerstände brauchen wir nicht die kann ich weg feuern
also wir brauchen ich hol gleich mal multimeter um das ganze nachzumessen dass das passt also
wir brauchen einen spannungswandler wir brauchen zweimal solche transistoren zum schalten und wir
brauchen einen microcontroller und diese komischen relays hier die lege ich einfach da mal hin der
schelle kommt weg wie viel strom das ist eine gute frage ich weiß nicht was maximal ist
achso nee gar nichts gar nichts ich muss gar nichts schalten ich muss gar nichts schalten ich muss
nee nee nee da läuft nichts drüber ich muss das hier schalten guck mal ich muss diese zwei
dinge überbrücken ich muss diese zwei dinge überbrücken das ist normalerweise normalerweise
ist das quasi so als button markiert die überbrücken und dann schaltet irgendwie ein relay und das
schaltet dann den motor also da geht überhaupt nichts drüber also das ist nicht so dass das
irgendwie da jetzt was weiß ich 10 ampere hat oder so also ich würde sagen gar keine
spannungspegel oder braucht das braucht das irgendwas ich das ist wobei ich habe keine ahnung
ich mache das jetzt probiere es jetzt einfach aus wurscht easy wir probieren ich mein mehr
als durchbrennen kann es nicht so muss ich den kram jetzt ranlöten ich habe überhaupt keinen
bock drauf muss ich auch noch kabel dranlöten was ist denn das mach video groß ja ok also ich
muss jetzt hier zwei kabel dranlöten an den spannungs wandler dann muss ich in esp 286 schon
weil ich keinen bock haben esp 32 zu opfern dafür opferlahn so eck esp 32 der kann da habe
ich noch genug der kann auch verrecken der kann implodieren ist mir egal ja besser besser und
billiger in dem fall habe ich nur spannungs wandler vielleicht fertig mit kabel dran
irgendwo irgendwo hier vielleicht mist alda ich habe kein bock das jetzt fest zu löten da muss
ich die lötstation dran machen er sieht nicht so aus na da muss ich trotzdem festlöten jetzt
ich habe auch gar keinen platz hier ich habe eigentlich überhaupt nicht gedacht dass ich
irgendwie so feinmotorik krams machen muss ich dachte ich mache den shelly dran und gut ist das
doch das doch alles kacke so haben wir das mal weg aber wir geben natürlich nicht auf wir löten
jetzt erstmal hier den spannungs wandler dann schließen wir den an bevor ich in esp 32 dran
mache machen das multimeter dran und gucken mal was denn da am ende rauskommt also ganz
wie was brauchen wir dazu wer weiß es das allerwichtigste der allerwichtigste champ
überhaupt ich muss ihn kurz holen
nicht nicht den lötschamp den apesolier champ den au und einen seitenschneider brauche ich
der apesolier champ so wobei ich brauche kein seitenschneider das ding hat ja oben
aus und billigen also ok wie lang muss denn der kram denn jetzt sein also da in out out in plus
in minus das macht die vm da oben sofort ok komm wir mal das machen lieber ein bisschen länger
als zu kurz zweimal da und zweimal von dem auch immer hier eigentlich das ende ist bei diesem
komischen teil so ok schauen wir mal also nehmen wir mal weiß die sind jetzt bisschen sehr
ungleichmäßig so weiß minus blau plus oder wie auch immer was ist was ist euch lieber chat sucht
euch aus gut so die lundstation kann ich nicht hier oben drauf stellen pass mit den spiegelungen
auf naja alles auf weiß sehr gute idee beste da weißt du am ende gar nicht was du brauchst also
die lundstation kann ich jetzt nicht hier hoch stellen weil ich habe schlicht und ergreifend
kein platz mehr auf dem tisch ja so holen wir mal das multimeter raus das brauchen wir jetzt auch
noch meine güde leute immer dran denken stecker raus wenn ihr so sachen offen stehen habt vor allem
da hier stecker raus immer stecker raus lötzen lötkolben bei gott ich habe keinen platz alter ok
ich stelle es hier so halb auf halb acht irgendwie hin ich habe jetzt ich habe jetzt das ding so
das steht auf meinem bein zum abstellen für den lötkolben das ist alles super safe hier
und weil ich lasse es nicht auf meinem bein stehen dass es mir dann auch ein bisschen zu viel ist
gut ich stelle zwar irgendwie nebenhin ok also machen wir das mal dran erstmal nur wir machen
erstmal nur den input dran input input ok ich habe ja auch keinen platz irgendwie so eine dritte hand
hinzustellen oder sonst was finde ich immer übrigens immer noch ziemlich gatschi bass dass man den
kram dritte hand nennt dass er das hört sich irgendwie sehr unanständig an so aber mal ein
bisschen was das hier excellent und andere seite excellent fragt mich warum ich manchmal so
rumspinnen und sachen vor mich er hinsagen muss dass das ist so erkennt mich tröpfel tröpfel
champ ok auf geht's also in minus weiß weißes kabel kann kann nicht auf den chat gucken aber
beide als ich irgendjemand fragt warum man nichts input unrunde das ist auch das ist
ziemlich jolo einstellung da also wirklich schön dran ist das nett vielleicht jetzt ist gut jetzt
ist schön ok machen wir das ding mal kurz aus so also dann schließen wir das doch mal an also
ungefähr gleich lang ist es immerhin also wenn ich das jetzt richtig richtig sehe das ding mal
kurz ein bisschen sauber machen dass das ganze staub beschützbar weg ist also wenn ich das jetzt
richtig sehe dann müssen wir das jetzt da dran anschließen 0 volt und 24 also ich vermute mal
die wollen mir damit sagen die wollen mir glaube ich damit sagen dass das da minus ist und das
daneben ist plus x killers dankeschön wie viel fläche der platine sind eigentlich auf 200 also
hier unten auf jeden fall hier unten auf jeden fall hier oben dort wo dieses also also eigentlich
nur das hier und und hier oben die die brauen dinger zumindest würde ich das als nupt so
interpretieren das ist ein lügen stift genau jetzt dann dann stöpseln wir das mal dran und
gucken ob das was bringt ob das macht gerade noch mal ein bisschen mehr isolierung ab
gut also was habe ich gesagt weißes minus blau ist plus also von der idee her müsste
das dann ich glaube ich habe heute echt keinen platz das war überhaupt nicht geplant dass
wird das überhaupt so fein motorische sachen machen muss ok also weiß ist ihr seht weißes
minus da beweis
und blau ist plus so wenn ich das jetzt einschalte dann sollte ich hier ja wer weiß ich weiß
ich wieder spannungswandel eingestellt das probieren wir mal aus es sollte zumindest
nichts explodieren und guck mal der leuchtet ja sogar ein bisschen der guck mal seht ihr
das seht ihr das das ding leuchtet brutals leuchtet übelst übelst krell guck mal hier
so dann dann gucken wir doch mal guck mal was da rauskommt gerade 22 volt abyssi viel
für ein esp 32 würde ich sagen das ist ein down down converter das ist halt toll jetzt
komme ich dann richtig dran müsste man eigentlich ich habe doch irgendwie so klemmen wo habe
ich denn meine klemmen dafür klemmchamp wo ist der klemmchamp hier da klemme beste
klemmen viel besser als diese andere krempel zack und zack zack haben wir das hier dran
klemmen gescheit lehm jawoll pock klemmchamp am start naja das ist nice also 22,1 jetzt
müssen wir das runter drehen auf 3,3 volt oder auf 5 geht auch weil der devon mini hat
einen 5 volt eingang glaube oder der eingang ist zumindest glaube ich 5 ja ja 5 volt aber
das hier durch erkennt guck mal da oben der 5 volt input also entweder können wir direkt
3,3 oder ist eigentlich egal so ihr seht ihr seht ihr was ne ihr seht nix ne seht ihr jetzt
was so jetzt drehen wir das mal runter bis wir hier irgendwie so ungefähr auf naja da
muss eine ganze weile noch drehen na geil alter das ist nicht dafür gemacht dass das
hier so kacke rumhängt was ein gefrickel alter ich drehe jetzt einfach ah gott ich
hab keinen platz mann kein platz ey leck mich beste musik dabei
habe ich nicht irgendwo noch einen kleineren schraubendreher der ist ein bisschen groß
hier so wo sind wir jetzt bei 9,5 volt ok alles klar jetzt 8,1 wir nähern uns wir nähern
uns das ist ein lm ja ich kann es jetzt nicht rumdrehen irgend so ein billiges teil jetzt
ist zugelassen für glaube ich 12 bis 60 volt oder so oder was das zu ich glaube zugelassen
ist von diesem schienerzeug gar nix aber ey es hat irgendwo ein selbst aufgedrucktes
ce logo keck so so na komm bisschen
na passt doch genau 5 volt genau 5 volt output alles klar wunderbar da kann ich jetzt ja
mein esp 2866 dran machen ohne dass er mir um die oren fliegt so stecker immer schön
stecker raus leute immer stecker raus sonst irgendwann abkratzen oder zumindest sicherungen
oder schalter und alles raus also jetzt haben wir das ding heißt im endeffekt ich kann
da jetzt mein esp 32 dran machen elektronik ja ungewolltermaßen alter eigentlich hatte
ich vor ich schalte das ding hier mit nem shelly und gut ist bis mir aufgefallen ist
das sind nur inputs beim shelly ich kann nur gucken ob was ob irgendwo spanung anliegt
und nicht selbst irgendwas schalten das dazu bräuchte ich ein shelly 2 mit zwei eingebauten
relays und das habe ich net da das heißt jetzt müssen wir selbst irgendwas bauen also einmal
spanungswandler esp 32 am start esp 2866 am start da müssen wir noch das motor flaschen
gleich drauf abfakt leute da kein bock drauf so ich spar mir irgendwelche irgendwelche
pins ich löte das ich löte das direkt hier dran hier kommt kommt direkt kommt direkt
hier dran wobei flaschen tue ich ihn vorher bevor ich ihn dran löte wer alles andere
wäre total pepega ja du du du du was das für multimeter hast du es von jesus geerbt
das ist irgendein frag mich nicht keine ahnung irgendein nicht all zu teures von amazon so
wir flaschen den jetzt erstmal hier tas motor aktuell ist tas motor drauf hat jemand zufällig
noch den webflasher für tas motor da gab es noch so ein neues tas motor webflash install
tas motor install powered by esp webtools genau das ding meine ich usb usb haben wir
da brauche mikro usb ich habe nur usb c gerade da hier hier liegt einer exzellent exzellent
exzellent so mikro usb richtig rum so flaschen also flaschen wir das ding quinhang usb 2.0
quinhang klingt klingt china chinesen esp mäßig so wir wollen tas motor englisch flaschen
genau quinhang your browser does not support web serial ok chrome chrome kann das exzellent
exzellent no device was connect usb 2.0 sehr das klingt gut install tas motor englisch
ja das mache ich install tas motor kann man dann auch gleich die web hat jemand das den
web installer in letzter zeit mal verwendet kann man dann auch password und so setzen
install tas motor erase device yup next install so er flasht ok von der idee her was müssen
wir denn dann machen also den hier den den transistor irgendwie noch dran da bin ich
immer ein bisschen planlos wie man den wie man das anschließt mache ich mal kurz kurz
aus falls man da jetzt irgendwelche wähler an sachen sieht habe den web installer selten
verwendet next scanning for networks ist gut dass ich auch schwarz gemacht habe kackel
enthält das password das klingt schon mal richtig alter mein wlan password ist so unglaublich
dumm jedes mal wenn ich das tippe muss ich grinschen connect device connected yeah visit
device naisu ich mache mich wieder an exzellent so tas motor ist am start also wir haben geflashten
esp 82 macht euch nichts draus ich werde einfach esp 32 sagen es ist kein esp 32 aber ist doch
vollkommen wurscht was es ist lises moment lises muss ich muss kurz die lises static machen
im dhcp make static sag einfach ab jetzt esp 32 kommt kommt das ist hoftor d1 mini ok nice
das bild wieder da ja das war das das war absicht das war absicht ok alles klar da ist
er kennst du stm ja kenne ich also ganz ehrlich ich mag ich mag die esp 32 die die klassischen
esp 32 am liebsten einfach was software unterstützung programmier support und und kam angeht integriert
das wifi das weiter der ganze zeit das problem was der raspberry pi pico hatte hatte kein
wlan dabei und ich weiß bis heute nicht warum man den versus in esp 32 nehmen sollte also
installiert es jetzt können wir abmachen so ok von der idee her ich mache das jetzt da
dran und also der kommt wird der kommt hier dran der esp 32 dann lockt er sich im wlan
ein ich hoffe er geht nicht kaputt und wenn er im wlan eingeloggt ist dann können wir
den transistor dran machen und gucken wie das funktioniert chat wir haben wir hatten doch
hier irgendjemand der richtig massive 6 hat anscheinend sich angehört hat was elektronik
angeht oder wie schließe ich den transistor jetzt richtig an ich tu mir da immer ein bisschen
schwer bei wie schließe ich den dann jetzt an die gp aus ordentlich an ip liegt monka
s nein wie schließe ich ihn das jetzt ordentlich an also base kolera genau also irgendwie hier
schaltet man ja dass jetzt irgendwie kraut für beides das ist kraut für beides und
das ist ach ich weiß es nicht das ist das ist zum schalten also hier kommt der gp au
dran oder wie hier kraut da der gp au und dort dann quasi plus von dem gerät was ich
schalten will oder wie ne kraut von dem gerät was ich schalten will oder da bin ich da bin
ich jetzt echt ahnungslos ok chat jetzt ist backseating erlaubt normalerweise ist backseating
immer hier nicht nicht angesagt aber in dem fall dürft ihr backseaten backseating erlaubt
ok also immer guck hier strom ist raus perfekt also ich brauche mal ein paar kabel aber ich
habe keine ich habe hier keine pin ah das ist doch alles rotz man ich schraub das nochmal
ab ich will das möglichst einfach haben kann ich nicht so ein fertiges fertiges jumper kabel
dafür nehmen zweifelsfall löte ich halt hier nochmal so ein ding ein das war nicht verkehrt
vielleicht sollte ich hier einfach nochmal ein paar pins ein paar pins anlöten ja ich
glaube ich löte nochmal ein paar pins also ok chat schreibt base an esp collector und
die mitte in die 12 volt crown verbindung vor dem ding aha also ok also von der idee
her also gpio schließe ich in der mitte an also hier da in der mitte kommt der gpio pin
dran und links und rechts das ding schließe ich quasi hier an die an die kontakte an oder
wie und das geht ich glaube ich glaube euch das jetzt einfach mal backseat chat ich ich
glaube ich das jetzt einfach einfach mal wenn wir gleich sehen ob es funktioniert ich meine
data sheet schauen hier data sheet da achso da pin belegung in der mitte in der mitte
ist base also in der mitte ist das was an den resp an den esp dran muss base mit widerstand
mit sowas fangen wir gar nicht erst an was denn für ein überhaupt da brennt nix ab
also da habe ich keine bedenken dass er irgendwas aber der hat der esp also der demo der d1 mini
hat am gpio schon einen frag mich nicht standardmäßig glaube ich glaube ich einen pulldown widerstand
dran das müsste doch eigentlich auch passen bevor du den transistor putzelst wir gucken
mal kurz da rein also was ist das ein pn 222 801 steht da glaube ich drauf ok schauen wir
mal was da was da steht 801 den gibt es gar nicht 5 volt was was mich weil es will er
mir sagen 60 60 volt dc was was
ich habe keine ahnung leute ich mache das was der chat sagt in dem fall ich mein komm
mehr als dass der transistor durchbrennt kann er wohl wirklich nicht passieren an der stelle
also ja dann löte ich mal irgendwo so einen habe ich hier noch was so ein ordentliche
kabels das hält ja noch nicht immer wie macht man das gescheit wie macht wie macht man das
gescheit weil ich sag mal so der da der muss ja anscheinend hier zwischen der muss ja hier
auf auf impuls normalerweise steckt man das wahrscheinlich auf irgendwie was drauf und
macht dann dort ordentliche kabel dran oder ich habe ich habe irgendwo auch noch steck
bretter und so aber frag mich jetzt nicht wo ja lochers da habe ich sogar auch noch
irgendwo habe ich auch noch aber das ich habe das alles nicht rausgesucht weil ich
nicht dachte dass ich heute so was basteln muss monka es ich weil wir können es ja mal
kommen wir machen das mal testweise wir machen wir machen das mal testweise jetzt und gucken
ob das überhaupt ob das überhaupt schaltet alles also da mache ich doch jetzt einfach
mal hier noch ein paar da löte ich doch jetzt hier mal was dran man das ist soweit auseinander
das kommt nicht zusammen möglichst möglichst genug platz ja und dann dann gucken wir mal
kurz leitung dran dann in schrumpfschlauch da brauchst du ganz schön kleine schrumpfschlauch
hierfür kommt probieren wir das mal das macht man wie gesagt wahrscheinlich macht man das
nicht so also was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe ist ich löte hier einfach zwei kabels
dran links und rechts und dann gucke ich mal ob ich noch irgendwie platine oder so hab
nur mal so von der idee her also das heißt wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe also sprich
der esp kommt in die mitte und die zwei seiten dann also esp kommt in die mitte und die zwei
seiten ist dann quasi das was ich dort zum überbrücken rein stecke sehe ich das richtig
ja dann mache ich mal das löte teil wieder an löten wir das mal dran
und dann gucke ich mal ob ich noch irgendwo eine gescheites gescheite platine oder so
hab wo man das machen können ach so ja passt passt ob ich das jetzt hinkriege ohne dass
ich irgendwas habe was das festhält das wird bestimmt pence jam pleite es wird richtig
pence jam wartet mal ich brauche irgendwas zum festhalten ich habe doch irgendwie so
ein stück knete dafür so was wo ist es denn weiß ich nicht ich habe vorhin alles vorm
tisch tisch tisch runter geschmissen in der kiste dass ich dass ich platz habe aber so
was können wir hier nehmen dafür hoffentlich hält es jetzt nicht ich habe hier alles runter
gefeuert vorher ich habe extra für so was normalerweise ein stück knete da kann man
das rein stecken und dann hält das also kein geld sondern wirklich knete und dann hält
das eigentlich ganz gut aber naja ok wir müssen wir probieren das jetzt mal freihändig machen
erstmal erstmal den hier warm machen bisschen lötsen dran dann sollte das doch eigentlich
mehr oder weniger selbst ich will es jetzt nicht zu heiß machen weil ich bin ich sicher
bin was ist so was ist so verkraftet hey massive freihand dran gelötet schön ist was anderes
aber es hat es hat kontakt ja es muss reichen so jetzt kann ich das vielleicht ein bisschen
besser fixieren weil auf der anderen seite schon was dran ist ja exzellent
aha aha es hält exzellent schön ist was anderes aber es hält habt den pn 222 noch
mal gecheckt maximal 600 milliampere auf dem collector versteht also kann es gut ok also
sollte es funktionieren oder ich schließe das ding jetzt einfach so an ich habe noch
drei ich habe noch drei reserve drei reserve transistoren da ich nehme ich nehme noch ein
schiff für den sub echt gespannt ob das jetzt funs da prog ok das war halt wie gesagt alles
nicht geplant wo habe ich den lötkolben hin da ok ich hätte den ich hätte das ding
vorher festlöten sollen aber jetzt können wir trick 17 machen guckt mal seht ihr das
steht wiener eins
exzellent ok du lernst bald löten ja da macht es nicht so wie ich hier aber ok das
sollte das sollte funktionieren so also nur dass ich nur dass ich das jetzt richtig verstanden
hab chat also wir nehmen jetzt den esp 32 der zwar kein esp 32 ich nenne ihn aber esp
32 32 und ich gehe beispielsweise jetzt sagen wir mal hier an was auch immer gpio d2 d2
ist durfte 3 so und damit schalte ich den ja sehe ich das sehe ich das richtig muss
da nicht irgendwie gemeinsamer ground oder irgendwie sowas angeschlossen werden ich guck
mir jetzt mal ich guck mir jetzt mal da was was an also pn 2222 arduino anschlussbild also
was ist das für ein komisches ding
der emitter muss auf crown vom esp ja gut aber wie schalte ich den dann ich muss den
ja mit dem gpio noch ein oder ausschalten können
aber dann habe ich doch 2 von 3 schon am esp dran und wie soll ich dann und wie soll ich
dann das andere da schalten brauche ich dann zweimal crown muss ich an die eine seite zweimal
crown kabel löten oder wie wie funktioniert das keine ahnung so hier also ok ground das
ist ja aber auch wieder bescheuert zeichnet man ein ordentliches bild man
stimmt
also gibt es dann irgendwie mal ein gescheites bild wo auch ich was mit anfangen kann
was für kack noobs hier sowas da kommt mal super high res high res high res image
immer so anschließend wie du es gesagt hast
so das nicht dargesteckt sein das ist dargesteckt da hat er in der mitte gar nichts dran doch
also das ist crown das ist 5 volt in dem fall 3,3 und normalerweise warum hat er das nicht
hier reingesteckt
ja nochmal ich wollte ja eigentlich auch ein relay dran machen aber ich habe nur so ultra
fette und die anderen finde ich gerade nicht
genau das orangene ist der gpio das orangene nur mal dass ich das das ich das breadboard
hier richtig verstehe das orangene geht dann quasi hier in die mitte ja
so das orangene geht in die mitte
das ist mir zu kompliziert das check ich nicht
wie habe ich denn das bei meiner tür gegensprechanlage gemacht da habe ich das auch da habe ich
dann irgendwie einen da habe ich auch einen widerstand dazwischen noch weiß ich doch
jetzt nicht mehr also ich muss auf jeden fall
moment wartet mal wartet mal ich glaube wartet mal wartet mal
m
wie schließe ich das denn an
wie würde ich das jetzt überhaupt anschließen ich meine so also was ich was ich kapiert habe
ist das ding muss auf den gpio drauf
wir probieren es wahrscheinlich wirklich erst mal mit dem relay aber nur von ihr also das
hier muss auf den gpio drauf so das hier muss auf ground drauf
aber ich muss das hier doch zweimal anschließen da
müsste ich dann dort irgendwie mit einem widerstand dazwischen noch was
ich machen muss ich muss diese zwei dinge überbrücken das dann geschah also wenn ich
diese zwei dinge überbrücke schaltet irgendein relay den motor an von dieser steuerung also
das funktioniert nicht mit dem transist excellent gut da kann ich gleich meine relays verwenden
und gut ist da muss ich einfach mal nachher noch die kleineren suchen ich habe nämlich
so ein 20er pack oder so gekauft dann ist besser dann dann lassen wir das dann lassen wir das
sein da fließt gar kein strom in irgendeine richtung glaube ich zumindest nicht weiß gar
nicht wie ist das wenn ich das überbrücke kein schimmer zumindest zumindest sollte definitiv
nix über den esp fließen von da ne ne ne ne wir machen das wir machen das mal mit lieber
mit den relays also wo habe ich die dinger hin da hier viel besser da weiß ich wenigst
was sache ist ich meine das sind immerhin gute guck mal immerhin gute Hongwei Relays
brauchst du einen potenzialfreien kontakt an der tor steuerung weiß ich nicht ob ich
das brauche da steht bestimmt irgendwo in diesem handbuch in dem nix wirklich sinnvolles
drin steht wir können mal reingucken wir gucken mal wir gucken mal ins handbuch also
das ding ist manual torantrieb so wie gesagt das handbuch ist hardcore ppega so
guck mal hier 13 14 13 14 was netz hat was also 13 13 15 14 10 anschlusswahl impuls das
hatte überhaupt kein bild hier oder was neun anschluss taster genau taster zum taster
anschluss taster taster nein das sind die eingebauten dinger taster taster anschließen
hier anschluss nur für potenzialfreie schließer kontakte verwenden genau ein knopf halt sozusagen
ich will quasi ein knopfdruck simulieren so also also mit dem relay wäre das halt
übelst easy ja hier anschläge anstöpseln und hinten schalten und gut ist das war easy
das machen wir jetzt auch wir schließen ich schließt jetzt das relay an fertig da weiß
wie es da weiß wie es ungefähr ungefähr was sache ist ok also du du du du du du du
du du du du bin gerade am überlegen ob ich nicht an den esp trotzdem noch in so eine
header leiste löte schnelle mal das wahrscheinlich ganz praktisch wäre welche nehmen wir da
ja super da muss ich aufpassen ich habe den graben schon mal runter geschmissen leute
wisst ihr wie schmerzhaft es ist so eine pin header im fuß zähl stecken zu haben ja ganz
schiebus den machen wir jetzt hier dran den machen wir jetzt hier dran den machen wir
jetzt hier dran da kann ich das nämlich besser besser dran stöpseln und mal kurz lötkolben
anschmeißen ich habe halt heute überhaupt keinen platz für irgendwas hier jetzt muss
das ganze mal ordentlich machen dass es gerade ist weil es ist überhaupt nicht gerade einmal
gerade und gut ist einmal gerade immer gerade es ist immer gut und nicht schlecht das ist
tatsächlich relativ relativ gerade
gleich haben wir es dran ach da hat er sogar einen analogen input der esp dann vergesse
ich immer nicht dass wir den brauchen würden aber wundert mich jedes mal wenn ich das sehe
so jetzt haben wir die header leiste dran sehr schön jetzt können wir das relay ordentlich
anschließen ja also also einmal relay wir haben plus wir haben minus also einmal auf
ground und wir haben den GPIO pin heißt ah ground ist da unten natürlich doof jetzt
da muss ich da muss ich auf der anderen seite auch noch ein dran löten na toll naja warum
nicht warum nicht dann wie macht man eigentlich ein wlan außenfühler und das dann auf was
keine ahnung ich weiß noch nicht mal was du gerade geschrieben hast
so jetzt müssen wir den anderen kram auch noch fest löten schnell andere seite zack
jetzt gucken dass es gerade ist na geil okay wunderbar gerade rxtx kann ich mir eigentlich
sparen braucht kein mensch hier brauche eigentlich nur die fünf voll und ground aber ich löte
den restlichen kram auch mal dran ich mann sind wir mal nicht so brauche ich da doch
nachher sieht man eigentlich meinen kopf alles fest alles gut ok so jetzt haben wir den kram
hier fest gelötet das heißt also wir haben das relay wir haben den schalter den machen
wir jetzt einfach mal hier auf gpio was ich den drauf d3 dann brauchen wir dann brauche
ist das mein gott die china chinesen beschreibung alle haben wir nicht richtig erkennen plus
ist das blaue kabel der geht auf 3,3 volt und das falsche und das ist minus der geht
auf ground sagen wir dahinten und oder ist es ein fünf voll ach ja da fällt mir ein
wir müssen den esp noch mit strom versorgen das heißt wir müssen mal kurz d1 mini pin
out gucken wo man eigentlich den strom ein anschließen kann v in wo ist denn hier der
anschluss davon ist anscheinend egal man kann ihn entweder auf 3,3 volt oder auf fünf
voll anschließen gleich smoke ja wahrscheinlich schauen wir was ist denn das für ein relay
hongwei hm ja hw 482 relay 5 volt ok ok 5 volt relay
na gut dann muss ich so rum dann muss ich an 5 volt stöpseln nicht an 3,3 an 5 und
ich muss unseren esp da müssen wir hier noch mal einem spannungswandel ein bisschen rum
stellen der esp muss ja auch noch mit strom versorgt werden das probieren wir jetzt aus
also im endeffekt muss ich da jetzt aber wo habe ich das multimeter hin monka es wobei
ich kann ja erstmal ein paar kabel dran machen habe ich noch ein rotes dann weiß ich wenigstens
was ist ja hier perfekt dann probieren das mal aus dann löten wir das erstmal den spannungswandel
noch mal dran so also das ist plus das ist minus leute kolben einschalten wenn dafür
dass es heute überhaupt nicht geplant verläuft das doch eins ganz gut so dann löten wir
mal hier mal die die die spannungsversorgung für den esp dran gibt ihm jawohl perfekt sehr
schön so und dann nehmen wir dieses zeug hier schmelzen please gut ah nee das ist zu
wenig passt die musik gerade dabei
gut so ist dran ja ich weiß nicht ob du bei mir so viel lernen kannst also das heute habe
ich ja wirklich kein plan von gehabt bis wann das jetzt blick ich wieder halbwegs durch
habe ich schon mal gemacht also das haben wir angeschlossen das heißt rot ist wenigstens
plus dann weiß ich bescheid gut jetzt messen wir noch mal kurz nach dass wir das um dass
wir das eingestellt kriegen auf 3,3 volt also einmal da und einmal da dann irgendwie den
stecker da mal rein stecker ist drin wir haben 5 5,9 volt wir brauchen 3,3 dass wir unseren
esp nicht schrotten weiß ich überhaupt was erkennt ihr erkennt gar nichts ja ihr seht
5,1 3,5 ok fast na wenn das nichts ist guckt mal hier
genauer einstellen kannst du es nicht mehr gut dann würde ich sagen schließen wir mal
den esp an und gucken ob er uns verreckt shit ich habe den ground pin belegt schon damit
jetzt brauche ich jetzt noch mal hat er nur einen ground was das was das für ein crap
alter der die chinesen waren zu geizig dem den zwei ground pins zu zu spendieren das
war er hat das genauer ein na geil ok dann mache ich mal kurz das relay ab ich will einfach
nur mal wissen ob der esp angeht wenn ich es jetzt hier dran stöpsel ok so also entweder
raucht der esp jetzt oder es wird funktionieren ich glaube ich glaube es funktioniert ja das
ist billig wo hat man 60 also er hat geplinkt geplinkt ist schon mal guck mal da ist er
da ist er erfunzt unser board ist da alive nichtsdestotrotz bringt uns das nix also wir
müssen noch mal hier alter strom raus ich muss ich muss jetzt den ground vom relay anschließen
ist ja was wir machen das ich bin jetzt da ganz schmerzlos ich löte das jetzt direkt
an spannungswandler mit dran dann ist gut dann haben wir das relay angeschlossen da
müssen wir noch mal kurz den lötkolben einschalten eine runde lötsinn dran so und dann da dabei
ich sehe nix leute ich sehe nix das ist vom vinkel her mega mega hängen geblieben ich
sehe nix was ist das nicht an ach lull ich habe ausgeschaltet anscheinend an und ich
wundere mich schon warum das nicht funktioniert das relay wird nicht ach scheiße man stimmt
jetzt habe ich das ja auf 3,3 eingestellt nur 5 volt man das ist ja kacke das ist ja
richtig kacke ok haha machen wir anders easy easy ab damit achtung ab damit wir müssen
doch wieder auf 5 volt einstellen ok das war das war ppega von mir so also plus und plus
also das blaue kabel muss zusammen wir machen das jetzt alles an den spannungswandler dran
und gut ist wenn ich nachher bock habe mache ich vielleicht noch zusammen auf irgendein
das muss jetzt alles zusammen so das muss zusammen da drauf und das gelbe und das da
muss zusammen drauf meine güte cam ach ja ups ok ok lötsinn wo ist er
haben wir ordentlich lötsinn reinbuttern hier in das ding ok das ist minus also so rum
kommt der ganze shit da jetzt dran excellent
jetzt aber jetzt aber jetzt müssen wir nochmal das ultimeter dran machen dass ich 5 volt
kriege so ich hoffe ich passe jetzt irgendwie auf ohne dass ich es komplett kaputt mache
ok so 3,3 volt das war natürlich bescheuert müssen wir es gleich nochmal machen wie eben
bloß in die andere richtung gut so 4,9 das sollte denke ich auch hinhauen ok
schauen wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert jetzt müsste eigentlich klappen ich muss
jetzt nur gucken dass ich den esp auf dem 5 volt pin anschließe weil ansonsten du brauchst
hier ein transistor um das relay mit 3,3 nee das hält er aus so also hier wartet mal
hab ich jetzt gemacht sekunde nee ist doch richtig ist doch richtig also erstmal erstmal
den esp anschließen so esp also wir brauchen ground und 5 volt so und jetzt sollte er hoffentlich
nicht abrauchen macht er nicht er blinkt das ist gut dann muss das relay ist auf minus
das hier muss das muss auf plus vom relay ok und das hier ist der gpio so der gpio kommt
da drauf und dann kommt das gpio auf gpio was auch immer d3 das relay hat schonmal geklickt
das relay hat geklickt das ist schonmal gut seht ihr hier unten das rote am relay das
rote ja ihr habt es eben gesehen glaube ich so das können wir damit jetzt schalten wenn
das funktioniert doch ihr seht dass es hier unten rot leuchtet mehr sehe ich auch nicht
so und jetzt gehen wir mal in das motor ich hab ja noch gar keine relays eingerichtet
das sollte eigentlich nichts passieren jetzt nee passiert auch nix das ding ist nicht da
warum doch ist da ntp server muss ich eintragen ntp server sekunde ich glaube ich muss euch
nochmal ausmachen konsole ich muss den ntp server setzen weil ansonsten
mag das motor nicht lange zeit so ich mein jetzt toggelt hier noch nix ist ja auch nicht
auch eingerichtet auf gpio 3 so jetzt müssen wir die pin d1 mini pin out jetzt müssen wir
gucken welche gpio pin welche also ich hab's auf d3 gemacht d3 ist was gpio d3 ist was
d3 ist gpio 0 gpio 0 ist immer das ist immer fail das mag er eigentlich nicht was wir lieber
auf gpio 4 also auf d2 eins daneben ok also richtung das motor ein ich stöpsel ich stöpsel
jetzt erstmal um eins daneben dran mit drei auf d4 ok configuration wie ging das jetzt
nochmal in das motor konfigure template nee doch oder konfigure konfigure template ist
glaube ich gewesen genau da kann man einstellen was sache ist also gpio was hatten wir jetzt
gesagt gpio ich hab's jetzt an 4 dran ist gpio 2 die benahmung leute was sich die was
sich die china chinesen ausgedacht haben ist mir vollkommen unverständlich warum man das
warum man das schalten kann äh warum man warum die d bezeichnung und gpio bezeichnung voneinander
abweichen meinen hätten sie doch gesagt scheiß auf aluino wir haben ihr eigenes namenschema
und gut ist oder hätten sie es wenigstens gleich genannt aber nee so auf was muss ich
ihn das jetzt schalten button nee auf off relay wahrscheinlich oder wobei das der weiß
er nicht dass es ein relay das ist was ist was ich schalte doch in relay will ich schalten
weil 1 2 keine ahnung ha es hat ge geplinkt macht es jetzt was nee da schalt da schaltet
nix nur mal kurz gucken ob das relay an sich an sich schaltet wartet mal
ja
hat
das
schalten gpio d4 so ist doch richtig ich kann mir das immer nicht richtig merken weil die
das motor sache ist nicht unbedingt so super eingängig unbedingt ja jetzt halt die frage ist
das überhaupt ist das das was ich schalte überhaupt jetzt das ding wie war das motor
konfigure zu konfig ging das noch mal ich bin da doch eigentlich schon gar nicht so verkehrt
oder ich mache jetzt mal gpio 3 nur mal ich sag dem das wäre angeblich noch mal ein relay
12 das musst du im konfig so ne war war ist auch falsch wo ich bin ist ist auch falsch wo ich
wo ich bin ist falsch und jetzt hätte ich jetzt einen weiteren weiteren das ist verkehrt also ich
habe umgesteckt ja wie macht man das noch mal ich will jetzt einfach dass es schaltet so konfig ist
noch richtig war das konfig module konfig module was genau gpio so wo habe ich dran habe ich gesagt
da das war was gpio gott meine gut benahmung hier 2 gpio 2 so ging das genau safe jetzt schaltet es
klick klick hört ihr das es kann durchaus sein dass es dass es das unterdrückt der das das das
filter ding ihr seht die led ja ne funst excellent ok gut dann können wir es jetzt ja ausprobieren
ihr habt klicken gehört hoge hoge strom noch mal raus gut so also von der idee her muss ich jetzt
da was anspringen wo habe ich meine ach nee die habe ich für den transistor verwendet
keck keck weight habe ich den habe ich runter geschmissen jeder hinten ist er nehmen wir einfach
so dinge hatte mal ich mache mal groß nehmen einfach so paar kabels dafür wobei das sind
so richtig kleine billigkabel nehmen wir nehmen die anderen gescheiten so
das ist ja auch bis sie bis sie schäpp
so nämlich von der idee her müssen wir jetzt
das da drauf machen da wo impuls steht
und dann sollte es dann sollte es eigentlich aufgehen
da an die andere seite
und das ganze jetzt da drauf
so wo müsste man hin also wenn ich das richtig sehe dass er da was erkennt
natürlich erkennt man da nix also normally open normally closed und das in der mitte
müsste dann wie heißt das bei relays immer kommen oder so was ich spannung ist aus wie
gesagt immer immer schön stecker raus machen ja immer schön stecker raus machen gibt gibt es
nun eine möglichkeit dass über home assistant in arduino apple ja ja kannst du danach auch man
kann es in alles integrieren wurde wie du willst wir wollen haben normally closed wollen wir haben
ne normally closed wollen wir haben also das da
das china zeug da passt passt ja gar nicht mal mein ding zum aufdrehen richtig rein
aber jetzt aber
So, dann machen wir mal an und checken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Normally Closed, was so viel heißt, wie wenn es ausgeschaltet ist, dann ist es eben
aus.
In dem Fall.
Sonst ist der Schalter die ganze Zeit geschlossen, ist ja richtig.
Ich will ja, dass der Schalter standardmäßig geschlossen ist, außer es will ja geht an.
Okay, Achtung, Achtung, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Es geht, Leute, es bewegt, ja, jetzt gehts wieder rein, easy.
Ja, jetzt muss ich das Motor nur noch beibringen, dass der das Relay nur einmal kurz schalten
soll.
Das geht doch irgendwie, also fragt mich nicht wo, aber man kann das Motor doch sagen,
dass der nur kurz, dass der nur kurz schaltet.
Weil es ist ja nicht so, als wäre Relay an, dann würde was passieren, sondern es ist
nur durch den Impuls, also quasi an, aus, sag dem Ding, jetzt fahr los.
Also muss ich quasi...
Das Motor Relay Impulse, ach, muss ich den Button machen, nee, das ist, das ist, Button
ist ein Input für das Motor, also das, was ich jetzt hier von Hand mache, oder...
Relay.
Lines and Shutters, exellent, der Chat denkt mit.
Ja, so was will ich haben.
So, die Frage, wie man das Z, wie man das richtig einstellt.
Relay, TAS Motor, Auto, off, ja, das muss sein, irgendwo, das geht garantiert, du kannst
das Motor alles einstellen, Puls Time, Puls Time festlegen.
Ja, genau, ja, so was, nun kommen wir zu den eigentlichen Einstellungen, dazu gibt es das
Motor, Puls Time, mit dieser lässt sich die Naht eingeschaltet werden, die Zeitdauer,
die du jetzt eingeschaltet bleibst, lässt sich dazu in zwei verschiedenen Auflösungen
einstellen.
Also, Puls Time, Puls, also gebe ich jetzt einfach mal an, keine Ahnung, Puls Time 10,
und dann würde es nach einer Sekunde wieder ausgehen.
Richtig, das ist richtig.
Puls Time, Puls Time 11, zum Beispiel, aber ist das 11, Remaining 11 von KS, okay, das
funktioniert das jetzt?
Schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal, okay, also, mal kurz, ah, easy.
Hat funktioniert, ja, schaltet automatisch nach einer Sekunde wieder aus, exellent, das
ist cool, kann man nichts sagen.
Sehr nice, sehr nice, jetzt stoppt es, und nochmal triggern.
Du musst beim Relay Normally Open, warum, warum, warum muss ich das, weshalb, man funktioniert
ja, Normally Open würde auch sagen, es ist standardmäßig überbrückt, Normally Closed
in dem Moment, nee, nee, nee, nee, jetzt, jetzt bin ich, warte mal, warte mal, du hast
recht glaube ich, warte mal, wie rum ist das, also Normally Open heißt, das Relay ist offen
und es leitet nicht durch, Normally Closed hab ich angeschlossen, ne, jaja, genau, nee,
nein, ich muss, ich, du hast recht, ich muss Normally Open nicht Normally Closed anschließen,
jaja, das ist richtig, du hast recht, ne, das wird noch nichtmal warm, du hast recht,
ich hab, ich hab Normally Closed eigentlich, ich muss Normally Open anschließen, ja, korrekt,
Chat denkt mit Sixthead, Hi, Hi IQ Chatting, Hi IQ Chatting, du, du, du, du, du, du, du,
ja, gut, ja, ja, ja, okay, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, das ist gut, okay, ja, ja, ja,
Jetzt habe ich zu schnell geklickt, ich habe gerade doppelt geklickt, das hat ihn verwirrt.
Ja, genau, so jetzt ist es nämlich geschlossen, also jetzt ist es nämlich nicht überbrückt
und nur für den kurzen, nur für den kurzen, es ist quasi wie ein Buttondrück, jetzt ist
es so, wie wenn ich den Button jetzt kurz drücke, dann geht es an, so nochmal kurz Button drücken,
so, bleibt das stehen und nochmal drücken, dann geht es, ja genau, exellent, hast du
auf der Arbeit auch mal ein Charo mit die drei, ja, ja, was ist das hier, das ist eine Steuerung
fürs Hoftor und die will ich auch remote steuern können, nicht nur mit Fernbedienung.
Ok, das funktioniert schon mal, ich bin begeistert, Chat, da haben wir doch schon mal was geschafft,
ich muss jetzt nur mal, wenn ich dann auf gehe, ich muss jetzt nur mal die bisschen kleineren
Relays suchen, weil ganz im Ernst, dieses fette Ding, Alter, für dafür, ist vielleicht
ein bisschen, bisschen oversized, ja, ja, aber es funktioniert, also kann man nichts sagen,
also für das, dass ich das jetzt selbst bauen musste, ist doch ganz ok, das passt jetzt
ins Gehäuse, ist unten genug Platz hier, guck mal da, das wird mit Heißkleber einfach
dran gepappt und gut ist, das passt schon ins Gehäuse, aber ein bisschen kleiner wäre natürlich
trotzdem nicht verkehrt, ja, nee Chat, nice, also, dann haben wir es doch hingekriegt, funktioniert
doch alles, funktioniert doch alles, ich werde das jetzt nochmal ein bisschen schöner bauen,
aber ohne euch dabei, weil ich muss jetzt erstmal ganz dringend aufs Klo und ich suche
mal meine kleineren Relays raus, weil das ist eine ganz schön, ganz schön fette, ganz
schön fette Konstruktion hier, machen wir es mal aus, zack, den Controller werde ich
auf jeden Fall weiter verwenden, schauen wir mal, Chat, es hat mich gefreut, dass ihr dabei
seid, ich gehe jetzt aufs Klo, wir sehen uns, bis dann im nächsten Stream, see you.